Speaker 1: Let's go to Mike from Massachusetts.
You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, do you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Long time listener First-Time Caller.
Also, obviously from my title from Massachusetts.
Happy to have someone from my home state doing
what you do.
Pleasure, pleasure.
I guess my question is a little bit, it's
a couple of years out before this is a real
concern, but for the 2024 election, obviously
a lot can happen between now and then.
But as things stand right now, there is a
real possibility that if Trump were to run,
he could win.
Yes, correct.
Absolutely.
So there's I believe there's an argument to
be made that Trump's attempt to overturn the
election in 2020 really came down to a handful,
or maybe a half a dozen or so people that
blocked him at key steps that would have given
him huge opportunities to actually achieve
what he was trying to do.
Given the increase of like self-described
MAGA candidates that we've seen running for
various state positions and theory and whatnot.
And you know, with Trump having the popularity
that he has and most likely going to keep
that popularity over the next three years
or so.
If Trump were to run and theoretically lose,
do you see a possibility where he could actually
pull off what he tried in 2020 or theoretically,
if he ran and won?
Yeah.
Could he then install enough people into key
positions that he could actually completely
change the system when, even after he's gone,
Republicans could run the whole run the show
regardless of what the votes are?
Speaker 1: You know, the latter one seems
far fetched.
I don't know that 80 plus year old Trump as
president in an even more kind of dazed and
confused state than he was in during his first
four years is really going to do that.
I think that that's kind of far fetched.
My I think the first concern you mentioned
is a more legitimate one, which is it's looking
good for Republicans in the House in 2022
on redistricting alone, never mind actually
flipping seats.
It's looking OK for Republicans in either
22 or 24 taking control back of the Senate.
I don't know that Biden gets reelected.
I don't know that if he bails and Carmel is
the nominee, that she wins.
So by what?
By January of 2025, you could again have total
Republican control of the White House, House
and Senate.
And that's really, really scary.
And even if they only have control of some
of those, could they somehow use whatever
resources they have to give a win to Trump,
even if he didn't earn it in the way they
fell short of in 2020?
I don't want to be hyperbolic, but I also
don't want to write it off.
I think there are real concerns about if Trump
loyalists control more governorships the House
and Senate in 2004, and if Trump narrowly
loses in 2024, that there is a lot that motivated
Trumpist elected officials could try in order
to put Trump in the White House, even though
he didn't win.
Do I think they would succeed?
I still think they probably wouldn't.
But the fact that we're even talking about
it in these terms is very scary.
Speaker 3: That's fair to my somebody.
To my latter point, I guess I'd ask.
It's not so much to Trump's benefit, but if
he were to win in 2024?
Yeah.
And let's say, like you said, Republicans
control the House, control the Senate, could
they, now that they've seen how close they
can get to actually overturning an election?
Could they spend that term, the twenty twenty
four point twenty eight setting things up
so they can essentially run the show going
down the road, either Trump go away.
Speaker 1: They could try.
Yes, I think I think that's a much more plausible
way, which is it's not about Trump per se.
It's really about others laying further groundwork.
Speaker 3: And this not a question.
Speaker 1: It's not even a conspiracy theory
in the sense that they've been doing it with
voter ID for 15 years.
They've been this is what they do.
They do it with redistricting.
So of course, they would continue to try and
find new ways.
Speaker 3: OK, that was more my question the
first time around.
I guess I didn't articulate that quite right.
But no problem.
I appreciate that.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: All right.
Have a good one.
I'm sure I'll be calling back again soon.
Speaker 1: All right, there's Mike from Massachusetts.
Let's go next to Jamie from Canada.
Jamie from Canada.
You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, how's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Thank you.
Speaker 3: I was just wondering, how do you
think that Biden's agenda is going?
Because we've had basically the Endless Frontier
Act, which passed the Senate surprisingly
did not pass.
That hasn't passed the House yet.
Then he has the American Rescue Plan, which
which he signed into law, and then he just
signed the bipartisan infrastructure into
law.
But that so that's like he's hitting three
so far, but technically.
But he also has the John Lewis Voting Rights
Act and then before the People Act or the
The Right to Vote Act or whatever they're
calling it now.
I was just wondering.
So he has about maybe six or seven pieces
of legislation on his agenda.
What realistically, what do you think we're
going to see being passed?
Speaker 1: Oh, it's such a tough question,
because.
You candidates make way more promises than
they can ever keep or make a reality.
At the same time, you also had Biden dealing
with COVID and the Delta Wave.
And I've expressed disappointment that more
hadn't been done.
My expectation is that maybe not by the end
of this year, but by the end of the first
quarter of next year, there will be some additional
major accomplishment by Joe Biden.
I don't know if it'll be the build back, better
spending bill or if it will be something else,
including items you mentioned.
But I think that the way I would say it is,
Biden's doing OK on getting some things done,
although it's starting to feel a little bit
light.
We had the COVID stimulus vaccination rollout.
Now we have a much smaller infrastructure
bill than initially proposed signed.
I think in order to get back to like a B.
He needs one more big piece of legislation
by the end of March of next year.
That's kind of my mindset right now.
Speaker 3: Uh huh..
And he said, I think he said this, but he
said, I'm going to use every trick in my book
to try to get this voting rights passed.
And he said, I'm putting Camilla in charge,
and I was just wondering what you thought
of that?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am unsure as to whether
the vice president can get it done.
I mean, there's no way to sugarcoat it.
I hope that she can.
I'm unsure.
And so far, she does not have major accomplishments
under her belt.
But that's, you know, it's just I'm not saying
it as a criticism.
It's just she just doesn't right now.
And she's not particularly popular right now.
I hope that she can do it.
I don't know if she can.
Speaker 3: That's fine.
One last thing before I go is that my realistic
expectations, my my overperforming hope expectations
for the Senate in 2022 is fifty four fifty
six Democrats, but I know realistically we
might get only fifty two or or maybe just
hold the 50.
Speaker 1: Let's just hope Republicans don't
take over, and I'm setting my sights much
lower than you.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because people are telling me you got to lower
the expectations, you got to think it's just
going to be 50 or 51 Dems,
Speaker 1: I think I think cautious optimism
is the way to go.
I appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: And yes, thank you.
Hope you have a nice day and Canada's really
nice.
It is a little bit chilly.
I love
Speaker 1: Canada.
We love Canada here.
Thank you, Jamie from Canada very much.
Appreciate the call.